panis aux antilles aussi les boissons
pétillantes ont beaucoup de succès il
n'empêche que la boisson traditionnelle
les antilles rs le ti punch voici
maintenant de recettes délivré par une
martiniquaise tchèque et des zestes
d'orage
prenez donc le zeste de 4 orange qu'il
vous faudra laisser macérer quatre jours
durant dans un litre de rhum blanc dans
le mélange ainsi obtenu fait fondre ou
500 g de sucre cristallisé laisser de
nouveau macérer et après trois jours
filtré pour obtenir cette merveilleuse
liqueurs à l'arôme si subtile le choix
tiens
ni les traditionnels d'avoir du 0 degré
à noël pour leur franche de noël sociaux
se rappelle serge darmon pour le sirop
d'amour commencé par faire cuire 200 g
de ses pales de groseille tropicale dans
un litre d'eau le sirop s'obtient en
faisant bouillir la décoction avec un
kilo 750 de sucre ensuite passé au
filtre pour recueillir le précieux siro
sans lequel aucun punch de noël ne
saurait se déguster ce soit fait à noël
pense que c'est à noël qu'on a le feu
eva